HE HAS A LEAD OF ABOUT 64,000.
MEANTIME, PRESIDENT TRUMP IS IN
PARIS RIGHT NOW.
HE WILL PARTICIPATE IN A
CEREMONY TO COMMEMORATE THE
CENTENNIAL OF THE END OF
WORLD WAR I.
THERE IS A BATTLE, IF NOT A WAR,
ON HIS IMMIGRATION POLICY AND
THE MATTER OF MIGRANTS CLAIMING
THEY ARE COMING TO THIS COUNTRY
TO AVOID PERSECUTION.
JOHN ROBERTS IS IN THE CITY OF
LIGHTS TONIGHT.
GOOD EVENING, JOHN.
>> GOOD EVENING TO YOU FROM
PARIS.
IT'S A LEGAL BATTLE WITH A
LAWSUIT BEING FILED JUST THIS
AFTERNOON.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS HE'S
DETERMINED TO DO WHATEVER HE CAN
TO STEM THE TIDE OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION INTO THE
UNITED STATES.
DEPARTING THE WHITE HOUSE THIS
MORNING, PRESIDENT TRUMP THROUGH
MORE FUEL ON THE IMMIGRATION,
SAYING HE STARTED TO DONATE A
PROCESS TO DENY ASYLUM CLAIM
MADE BY ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
>> I JUST SIGNED A PROCLAMATION
ON ASYLUM.
VERY IMPORTANT.
THEY HAVE TO COME IN THROUGH THE
PARTS OF ENTRY.
THAT TO ME IS A VERY IMPORTANT
TO ME.
>> THE ACTION DREW AN INSTANT
LAWSUIT FROM THE ACLU, BUT NOT
IMMEDIATE BACK UP FROM HIS
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
MATT WOULD OCCUR SAYING THAT THE
PRESIDENT MADE A STRONG
STATEMENT SAYING ENOUGH
IS ENOUGH.
WE ARE CONTINUING TO PROVIDE A
PATH TO PROTECTION FOR THOSE WHO
TRULY NEED IT WHILE STOPPING OUR
GENEROSITY FROM BEING ABUSED.
>> I REITERATE, WE NEED DEMOCRAT
VOTES.
THEY NEED TO PASS NEW
IMMIGRATION LAWS BECAUSE THEY
ARE FLOODING OUR COUNTRY.
WE ARE NOT LETTING THEM IN.
BUT THEY ARE TRYING TO FLOOD OUR
COUNTRY.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL BE IN
PARIS TO MARK THE 100TH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE ARMISTICE
THAT ENDED WORLD WAR I WHILE
HE'LL HAVE A BILATERAL MEETING
WITH EMMANUEL MACRON, A MEETING
WITH VLADIMIR PUTIN HAS BEEN PUT
OFF.
>> I DON'T KNOW IF WE ARE SEEING
EACH OTHER IN PARIS.
>> FOX NEWS HAS BEEN TOLD THAT
AFTER PRESIDENT TRUMP RETURNS
FROM PARIS, HE AND HIS ATTORNEYS
WILL MAKE A DECISION WHETHER TO
SUBMIT TO AN INTERVIEW WITH
SPECIAL COUNSEL ROBERT MUELLER.
>> RIGHT NOW I'M THINKING ABOUT
THE WORLD.
I'M NOT THINKING ABOUT SIT DOWNS
OR NOT SIT DOWNS.
>> THE PRESIDENT'S TEAM HAS
PREPARED SEVERAL ANSWERS, BUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS NOT DECIDED
HE'LL GIVE IT TO MUELLER.
>> THERE IS NO COLLUSION.
IT'S A WHOLE HOAX!
>> THE PRESIDENT WEIGHED IN ON
CONGRESSIONAL EFFORTS TO PROTECT
THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION,
TAKING AIM AT ARIZONA REPUBLICAN
JEFF FLAKE, TWEETING, JEFF
FLAKE, HE DOES NOT WANT TO
PROTECT THE NONSENATE CONFIRMED
SPECIAL COUNSEL, HE WANTS TO
PROTECT HIS FUTURE AFTER BEING
UNELECTABLE IN ARIZONA, THE
CRIME OF DOING A TERRIBLE JOB.
PRESIDENT TRUMP ALSO RAILED THE
DECISION BY AN OBAMA APPOINTED
DISTRICT JUDGE IN MONTANA TO
BLOCK HIS PLANS TO BUILD THE
KEYSTONE XL PIPELINE.
>> I THOUGHT IT WAS A POLITICAL
DECISION MADE BY A JUDGE.
I THINK IT'S A DISGRACE.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP DID SEE GOOD
NEWS.
THE NINTH CIRCUIT COURT OF
APPEALS RULING AGAINST HIS PLANS
TO END THE SO-CALLED DOCTORAL
DACA
PROGRAM, IT KICKS IT TO THE
SUPREME COURT WHERE
PRESIDENT TRUMP CEMENTED A 5-4
MAJORITY.
IN A RECENT RADIO TALK SHOW,
FRENCH PRESIDENT MANUEL A CROWN
THAT EUROPE NEEDED TO DO MORE TO
PROTECT ITSELF, WHICH MIGHT
INCLUDE A TRUE EUROPEAN ARMY TO
PROTECT
AGAINST THREATS SUCH AS RUSSIA,
CHINA, EVEN IN THE
UNITED STATES.
BEFORE HE LANDED PRESIDENT TRUMP
TWEEDY, PRESIDENT LECRONE OF
-- IN ORDER TO
PROTECT ITSELF FROM THE U.S.,
CHINA, RUSSIA.
VERY INSULTING!
BUT PERHAPS EUROPE SHOULD PAY